bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour ce nouveau ou binaire je suis ravi
de vous retrouver ça faisait quelques
moins qu'il n'y en avait pas eu et
aujourd'hui nous allons aborder plus en
détail le package et issam al jissah
mari on l'a déjà abordé l'année dernière
c'est un package qui permet de faire des
tableaux publiables quasiment en l'état
on l'a vu on peut faire des tris à plat
des tris croisés et au revoir toutes les
options sont disponibles d'enfer on peut
faire beaucoup plus de choses avec elle
a fait des tests de comparaison on peut
rajouter des intervalles de confiance on
peut également on le verra avec ti
belkhadem savary le calcul et les
statistiques personnalisé faire par
exemple un tableau d'incidence et puis
il ya toute une série de fonctions pour
représenter aussi les résultats d'un
modèle multivariée ou voir calculée
plusieurs modèles universels a volé bref
on va avoir pendant la session
d'aujourd'hui le temps d'explorer plus
en détail tout ce qu'il est possible de
faire avec des tice vague
et puis comme à l'habitude je vous
partage mon écran c'est comme ça que
nous allons travailler du coup
aujourd'hui je vous rappel pour celles
et ceux qui suivent le live en direct la
possibilité de poser vos questions dans
le chatt youtube et pour les autres vous
avez toujours la possibilité de
retourner sur site analyseur
pour poser vos questions dans les
commentaires
alors pour aujourd'hui nous allons que
commencer
je vais vous retirez la bannière bouzid
écran
correctement et donc nous allons
commencer déjà à recharger tout
simplement le package qui se marient
dont quelques fonctions on va faire un
script garder les bonnes habitudes donc
je vais créer un script on va baisser un
peu l'écran on va charger mémoire le
package
geeti se marie
pour rappel ainsi les poster sur votre
ordinateur vous allez sont les package à
droite vous cliquez sur install et vous
sélectionnez getis mairie pour faire
installer
jeudi sur la nuit
et vous validez pour l'incendié le
package s'il est déjà salée on a
simplement à le charger mémoire je veux
aussi nous mettre rapidement le package
ce label en mémoire pouvoir décrire le
jeu de données qui va nous servir à
l'usagé et je vais enregistrer tout de
suite
je vais faire c'est enregistré le
package le script du jour et je voulais
déposerait comme d'habitude
sur le site des binaires alors on veut
qu'il y ait aujourd'hui en particulier
en jeu de données dans la plupart des
exemples ce jeu donnait cette l1 on va
rapidement regardez à quoi il ressemble
et donc je vais appeler la fonction
loupe fort du package de la belge
on voyait ce jeu de blood et possède
huit variables qui est une première
barrière qui s'appelle trt qui n'est pas
le type texte d'une variable âgées
marqueur qui sont des variables de beule
donc c'est à dire des variables
numérique il plus de facteurs les
variables states et wild avec différents
niveaux t1 t2 t3 t4 et puis pourquoi il
vaut 1 2 et 3 une variable response qui
ne variaient de d'hypnotiques odéon 0 1
donc elle apparaît ici comme variable
entière et je n'arrive pareil tf donc
odéon 0,1 et puis ne dure et qui sont
des mois jusqu'à la censure de la base
ou au décès on est sur un jeu de données
qui sont issus d'une données de patients
atteints d'une tumeur cancéreuse
typiquement des données de type
épidémiologique l'intérêt de ce jeu
donnait ses ouailles et il à différents
types de variables mais ça va du coup
nous permettre de nous servir d'exemple
front du tout au long de
de cette session et puis si je tape
directement dans la console on voit que
nous avons 200 observation pour lui que
leur a envoyé la variable traitement
d'alerté dans une variable en fait qui
angels à brügg be en fait c'est une
variable de type catégorielles mais qui
est coté seulement qui est connu ici
sous forme textuelle
alors on va recharger ici
les données il puisse qu'on va faire
quelque chose qu'on avait déjà fait
c'est tout simplement un triathlon et
donc la fonction de base que l'on va
déjà suivre city be liable samarie ci
réplique tibet elles se marient souvent
l'objet warriors
ça va me un très à plat et il va
apparaître directement dans le viewer
ici en bas à droite alors la première
chose que fait tibet al-chammari s'est
déjà d'essayer de deviner quel est le
tic deux variables puisque d'antibes il
se marie en a deux grands types les
variables catégorielles et les variables
conquis alors si une variable est de
type facteur ou si jamais une variable
est de type textuel 1 comme trt eh bien
elle va être comprise comme une variante
catégorielles et par défaut ce que l'on
a ce sont les effectifs et les
pourcentages donc sur 200 observations
98 en drogue et et vous avez donc du
coup le pourcentage 49% les deux
variables qui sont facteurs ici states
airways sont traités comme des variables
catégorielles alors on ensuite un type
particulier c'est quand vous avez une
variable numérique qui a moins de dix
valeurs différentes
elle va être aussi catégorisé comme une
variable catégorielles alors que si
votre variable numérique a plus à 2,10
modalités différentes de valeur unique
elle valait bien être traité comme une
variable continu
on a ici l'exemple d'une femme continue
qui est la variable marqueur le vems
donc c'est la variable ici s'appelle
marqueur vous voyez ici qu'une variable
ont des étiquettes de variables et
qu'elles seront directement reprises
et donc par défaut ce qui nous est
représenté une émission note du tableau
c'est la médiane elie qr interchange ce
qu'on appelle aussi les intervalles
interquartile c'est à dire le premier
kart il est le troisième quartier donc
les vélos catégorielles sont ici
représentés
directement avec cette valeur résumé ici
la valeur médiane ce qui est également
le cas
de la variable âge ce que vous remarquez
aussi pour ces deux variables là c'est
que du tice marie a calculé le nombre de
valeurs manquantes effectivement il ya
un sac ou de valeurs montantes qu'on
peut voir avec free canal de quetsches
nerfs
si je prends mes fonctions freinage et
que la clique sur eux hommes vous voyez
que sont la variable âgées la variable
marqueur nous avons 11 et 10 valeurs
manquantes et ils ne sont indiqués ici
sous l'intitulé hanoi
autre élément à retenir ce sont un
certain type de variables catégorielles
alors les variables qui sont codées en
oui non qui sont alors plus tôt enrayer
ce n'est pas prête et textuelle ou qui
sont codées en tout face de manière
logique qui sont codées numériquement
comme 0 et 1 sont perçus comme des
variables dichotomie c'est à dire des
variables catégorielles avec deux
modalités et par défaut jean marie vous
les présente de manière un peu
particulière
au lieu de nous dire que il y a 112
personnes qui sont décédées et donc nous
aurions deux cents à 112 90 personnes
qui ne sont pas mes cd pour les
variables catégorielles il présente plus
la catégorie wii ou la capitaine will do
ou la catégorie une et ont donc on a ce
cas là sur beijing died est sûre tu
meurs response il est important de
retenir qu'une variable
dichotomique 1 c'est à dire c'est une
barrière qui a été leur gueule à deux
modalités on verra tout à l'heure on a
des manières de sélectionner que les
varier d'un certain si vous prenez bien
une variable dichotomique est un type
est un sous type de mariage
catégorielles avec seulement deux
modèles
avant d'aller plus avant et d'explorer
toutes les possibilités que nous offre
jetty c'est ma vie on va juste
rapidement voir la notion de thèmes ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que jay this
marine il est possible de modifier très
rapidement par dm un certain nombre de
deux des faits particuliers voyez qu'ici
les décimales sont représentés par un
point à l'américaine et puis voyez on à
la médiane est titulaire qui nous sont
données en en anglais pareil pour
animaux alors
donc dit ismael vous avez plusieurs
fonctions qui commence par thème lorsque
of duty c'est ma vie y est vous avez ont
surveillé différents thèmes qui sont là
on peut regarder
directement les ailes qui sont
disponibles
avec le fichier dead
on a tout d'abord thème justice
américaine journal qui permet de choisir
un thème qui propres à certains
certaines roues revue alors en
particulier le land 7 le new england
journal of medicine à unjat main vous
avez un thème company pour un tableau un
peu plus serré
le thème printer où c'est quand vous
voulez forcer un certain type de sortie
on verra plus tard qu'on peut laisser de
jti si mallory faire ce qu'il veut tmg
this my language va nous intéresser
parce qu'on permet de traduire du
tysabri dans différentes langues et
enfin vous avez éventuellement tmg qui
se met huit mille st on y revient on y
reviendra mais ce thème là permet de
dire que par défaut
au lieu de représenter la médiane et
l'inter l'intervalle interquartile pour
les variables numérique on préfère avoir
plutôt la moyenne et les quartiers on
verra qu'on possible modifier de manière
manuelle
alors ce qui m'intéresse ici je vais
vous montrer un exemple par exemple le
thème license sa mj tit se marie djamal
27 si je définis du coup le m lang sept
jeux refaire mon tableau
toujours en anglais mais vous verrez du
coût des petites subtilités par exemple
pour le land 7 c'est un point médian qui
sert de séparateurs de décimales et puis
il ya deux trois autres ajustements qui
sont faits par rapport à des pratiques
propres au journal c'est indiqué plus en
détail dans la vignette ou propre mais
c'est notamment le cas pour des
intervalles de confiance qui vont être
présentés n'ont pas été intérêt mais
lequel l'onglet
retenez il ya quelques jours nous qui
sont implémentés ce qui va surtout nous
intéresser ici c'est comment est-ce
qu'on passe en france est donc ces
thèmes du tysabri
langue watch et là on va avoir plusieurs
options d'une part on a indiqué fr pour
dire que l'on veut plutôt une interface
en français mais en français le
séparateur de décimales c'est la virgule
donc on va pouvoir paramétrer sa
décision marque une cuite ô combien il
ya aussi la question du séparateur de
milliers parfois les anglais utilisent
la virgule pour séparer les milliers en
français c'est normalement un espace
dont huit marques qui est l'option pour
modifier par défaut le séparateur de
milliers je vais refaire mon graphique
et si vous maintenant au lieu de marquer
variés bon il ya marqué caractéristiques
en français avec les actions onoda été
remplacé par ben quand les séparateurs
de décimales sont bien la virgule et
voyez les notes de match les notes du
tableau donc 10 médiane en français et
eux y pour interval interquartile qui
est la nation française un duo en deux
interprètes shields à vannes ils tuèrent
comprenez qu'on peut très facilement
changer la langue utilisée par tidiane
sow mal
ce qu'on va aborder maintenant et on va
revenir un peu sur les éléments de base
c'est comme c'est la différence
électeurs et vous allez voir en fait
theresa may be est passé il souffle donc
par défaut lorsque l'on passe un
tableau de données data folle et
matinales se marie il va vous faire le
résumé entrée du tri à plat de toutes
les variables sauf que si vous avez un
tableau très gros on n'a pas besoin de
tout donc on va pouvoir indiquer à tibi
elles se marient les variables à
intégrer d'un tableau avec le paramètre
include
include à une syntaxe assez souple et ça
ça aussi les avantages du tibet elle se
marie et de katie se marie en général
qui s'inscrit dans le times on peut tout
d'abord indiqué
un vecteur qui contient les noms des
variables qui nous intéresse par exemple
mariam stéitsch grade
âge mais trt
donc l'âge indique un vecteur qui
contient les noms des variables inclus
entre guillemets
mais mon tableau prend directement les
variables considérez ceci dit ils se
marient nous autorise aussi d'avoir une
syntaxe à la taille diverse un peu comme
des plats hier donc j'aurais pu mettre
en fait plutôt que donner des vecteurs
textuel qui contiennent le nom un jeu
utilise et et ses lecteurs
qui se marient donc si j'invite le nom
des variables sont nickels guillemets ça
va bien compris en complexe et donc en
fait on va utiliser tous les électeurs
du tailles diverses c'est ce qu'on
appelle en fait la syntaxe tidy select
et voyez là je peux afficher les mêmes
variables notre avantage c'est que ça va
l'utiliser tous les raccourcis qu'on
connaît par exemple je pourrais tu te
faire les passes et comme mon frère dans
un selex
indiqué
et de pointer pour dire je veux toutes
les variables économiques qui vont de
âge at stake mai puis éventuellement
utiliser la fonction start scrive et
toutes les variables qui commence par un
thé
donc là
restait alors on as marqueur puisque si
je reprends d'autres tableaux
on a entre âge et steve marker donc on
essaie de ce jeu là plus les variables
qui commençait partait donc on a eu trt
et et nf donc on peut utiliser tous les
sélecteurs du taille diverse qui est
bien pratique
je vais revenir
un tableau un peu plus court
dans des séries comme hiver je vous
avais conclu steve hinds weave vous
pouvez aussi dire par exemple tout sauf
si je fais - stand gens
alors j'ai une erreur parce que j'ai
fait une faute de frappe
ça veut dire tout sauvetage
donc je vous renvoie au cours sur dix
cas hier mais on va retrouver les mêmes
éléments
l'intérêt c'est qu'on peut très
facilement faire un tableau croisé donc
supposons je demande à voir le tableau
avec h stage et brad spence
vous voyez ce tableau là par défaut le
triathlon avec du coup ma médiane pour
l'âge et puis la répartition pour les
autres variables mais si je veux faire
un tableau croisé je peux directement
indiquent-ils variable supplémentaire
avec thé avec bye donc la variable qu'on
voit passer à paille c'est forcément une
variable catégorie puisque on va faire
une colonne par sous catégorie et on
peut en passer une seule la balade donc
si je fais bail et rt
on ne retrouve
à avoir un tableau croisé et je vais
avoir du coup l'âge médian pour le
groupe grunge et là je me dis encore le
groupe rugby et puis la répartition avec
les pourcentages en colonne pour la
variable testage dans chacun des deux
sous groupes
on peut les un peu plus loin avec la
fonction had aux rôles alors hanovre all
c'est une fonction qui s'ajoute aux
résultats publiés se marient donc le
plus simple pour appliquer à d'autres
rôles c'est de passer par un bail
mais si j'applique un rôle savard a noté
une colonne supplémentaire qui va être
la colonne avec l'ensemble des résultats
de du paramètre bail on a donc ici une
colonne pour à une gold pour b on est à
une colonne total donc c'est le principe
de adopo à nouveau peut prendre deux
options jean option last si je la passe
a toujours ça me permettra de rajouter
makan total à la droite n'est pas de
l'eau et non pas à la gauche et puis je
peux également changer le contenu si je
veux pas avoir total elle dégaine de son
jeu peut du coup passé avec le paramètre
comme la belle le texte que je souhaite
afficher donc moi ce que j'aimerais
afficher sa serait par exemple
ensemble
effectif total
et blanche au col la même si un nombreux
je veux indiquer l'effectif total je
peut l'indiquer en utilisant des
accolades dix ans maintenant dont les
accolades
la valeur complète
ici je veux que en somme tout affichant
gras je peux ajouter des doubles étoiles
cdu marc daoud un qui me permet du coup
d'indiquer que le mot ensemble devrait
être affichée en dehors
donc ce qu'il faut retenir et on verra
différents endroits du code 1 2 c'est
qu'on va pouvoir à l'endroit indiqué
certaines valeurs affichées ce un syndic
toujours avec des accolades et en fait
les paramètres qui sont affichables
entre accola du dépens de chacune des
fonctions mais vous la trouvez toujours
dont l'aide donc là par exemple je
pourrais faire
l'aide de avoir vos petits billets elle
se marie
vous voyez du coup ce paramètre comme la
belle et on voit que par défaut un col
label il est ici donc vous voyez tout de
suite comment utiliser le gras comment
retrouver le compte n 1 dont il n'a pas
besoin de tout savoir arthur il faut
juste savoir a
retrouvé un temps l'aide les éléments
qui sont et qui nous sont nécessaires
alors
maintenant
vu comment faire
tableaux croisés ce qui pourrait être
intéressant dans notre tableau c'est de
pouvoir personnaliser les statistiques
affichées par exemple je voudrais avoir
la moyenne avec article pour les
variables qui sont continus
pour ça on va avoir recours aux
paramètres statistiques qui ont des
paramètres les plus puissants de tibi
elle se marie ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que ça fait partie des paramètres
qu'on va pouvoir personnaliser variable
part variable et donc du coup il a une
saveur un peu particulière
pour les paramètres de tbilissi maliki
veut qu'ils peuvent s'appliquer
indépendant part variable en fait vont
recevoir les paramètres sous la forme
d'une formule donc c'était à petite île
ou d'une liste de formules qui de la
forme sélection des variables t-il
valeur du paramètre alors
faire statistiques on va créer une liste
et supposons par exemple que je veux
d'abord modifier
ce qu'on va afficher pour la variable
âge donc je peux indiquer le nom ville
variable
tilde et on satistiques ont indiqué ce
qu'on veut afficher alors pour connaître
les statistiques disponibles il suffit
de regarder l'aide d'un de tvr sa mairie
parce que pour le paramètre statistiques
il expliqué en détails et on vous
explique tous les paramètres qui sont
disponibles ici et pour les barbes
continue voyez on peut avoir mine pour
la mienne deal pour la moyenne et sd
pour les quartiers donc ce que
j'aimerais présenter pour ma part c'est
la moyenne entre accolade nîmes
et je voudrais mettre entre crochets
les quartiers donc là avec sd
il faut comprendre c'est que ce que ça
nous permet c'est vraiment de donner si
je m 1 m de points avant la moyenne je
peux en fait on écrit une sangle peps et
les à collègues disent à quel endroit de
ce texte n'a pas changé par les valeurs
rencontrer je mange de résultats
et toujours
et pour la variable h on représente
attend m 2 points la moyenne et les
quartiers entre crochets
ce qui se passe
supposons je mette une autre variable
parker une autre variable
continu
la la modification que j'ai faits ne
concerne que la variable âge donc pour
la variable âge j'ai une présentation
de la moyenne et les terres type alors
que pour marqueur j'ai toujours ma
médiane et
les intervalles interquartile donc une
manière ce qu'on voudrait pouvoir dire
c'est pour tout les malades à
ce qu'on aimerait c'est que pour toutes
les variables de type continue appliquer
ma modifications et ça ça peut le faire
puisque en fait à gauche ici dutil donc
cliqué tout la syntaxe tous les
électeurs du tagi select mais on a un
nouveau sélecteur qui est proposée par
guy ti c mon briquet on continue ou ce
qui veut dire toutes les variables
continue
et en faisant ça
je vais me qui est mon paramètres
pour les deux variables qui sont
continues vous voyez à la fois à des
marqueurs ont été concernés
du coup on a aussi
d'autres ses lecteurs généraux qui sont
par exemple vous avez hall déco tonus
pour sélectionner toutes les variables
dichotomique ici se serait tu meurs
qu'il avait considéré vous avez aux
catégories comme qui permet de
sélectionner toutes les barrières
catégorique ce qui serait ici states et
tumeurs puisque je vous le rappelle les
variables économiques sont un sous type
2 et catégorielles et vous avez dans aux
catégories paul l'option de dire du
tonus et gagnent face pour lire toutes
les variables catégorielles sauf les
variables dichotomique
donc là
nous avons vu qu'on pouvait faire une
personnalisation pour une variable
continu et pour les variables continue
dans le fichier des deux voiliers qu'on
a accès à beaucoup de choses la médiane
à l'écart type la variance au minimum le
maximum l'ensemble des personnes t-il
donc sous la forme p12 pour le douzième
personne tine donc la médiane ça
pourrait aussi être équipés 50 et
l'intervalle intervertissent donc des 25
et 75 ont pour les plus avancés qu'au
est passé votre fonction personnalisée
et pour les variables catégorique on est
un petit peu mon élection mais on a
entre autres le pourcentage en petites
haines end le grand âge donc c'est le
dénominateur et à un pourcentage mis en
forme donc par exemple je pourrais dire
que pour les variables catégorique
ce que j'aimerais vous présenter
c'est le pourcentage
alors
des fonds qui se bat lui ne rajoute pas
le petit symbole course en c1 nous
l'indiqué
avons donc p et puis j'ai envie de dire
end sur grand m donc pile de petits pubs
qui lisait artiles 30 m
en faisons ainsi je vais remplacer
l'affichage par défaut des variables
catégorielles on le d'avoir
l'effectif puis pourcentage on a
directement le pourcentage ici est entre
parenthèses
à
28 slash 98 alors je vois ici une petite
question dans le chat qui nous dit mais
pourquoi les cartes il doit s'écrire
dans les crochets et les a quand même
petite précision
les accolades c'est pour dire à cet
endroit là accolades et des accolades
c'est pour dire à cet endroit là je veux
affiché
l'écart type les crochets c'est ça c'est
moi qui les ai mis en disant moi je veux
que l'écart type soit affichée entre
crochets si j'avais voulu afficher plus
tôt
ceci
les micros de gens mais tu sais on nomme
dick hajiti se marient comment il faut
mettre les choses en forme donc là j'ai
réutilise les crochets comme un exemple
parce que parfois on met les choses
entre parenthèses ou entre crochets mais
c'est vraiment chacun qui choisit en
fait de
délais des éléments en fait qu'on va
avoir en fait ce qu'on donne c'est une
chaîne de caractères ici qui indique
comment est-ce qu'on veut afficher la
cellule et simplement les accolades
indiqué l'endroit où ici en affichant la
moyenne ici on affichera la quartier
tout simplement
alors
si je continue sur mes balles le
quartier de l'ariane d'accord qui sont
représentés ici
par défaut
vous voyez les différents éléments qui
sont les différentes catégories sont
présentés dans l'ordre du vecteur
d'origine donc si je vous représente 1
comment le codetras yahoo le stage
c'est un facteur avec les modalités un
et deux t3 t4 et donc du coup on a
présenté dans cet ordre là si vous avez
une variable de type textuel
interlocteurs ça sera dans l'ordre
alphabétique on peut éventuellement
indiqué que ce qu'on aimerait s'est
présentée de la boue d'élite est la plus
fréquente à la modalité la moins
fréquente ça ça peut se faire avec un
autre paramètre qui est le paramètre
saute
alors comme tous les autres domaines qui
font une crise sur quel variable
appliquée dont je veux dire pour les
variables cet ego riels
et je indiqué free comme si pour changer
l'ordre des variables catégorielles il
dira que pour les barrières
catégorielles
jeu les affiches chez de la plus
fréquente
à la moins fréquente alors attention le
tri se fait sur le total il se fait pas
sur la colonne armes sur la colombie se
fait sur le total et au total
t2c 54 observations t1 53 t4 50 et et
3,43 donc là ça a trié de la modalité la
plus fréquente allamand fréquentes sur
l'ensemble du fichier
pourquoi ici c'est hors catégorie quand
il sait pas ce qu'on pourrait décider
que d'avoir plusieurs catégories les
dires certaines jeu à l'étrier à l'autre
encore une fois tout les options comme
s'appliquer variable part variable
ce qu'il faut aussi retenir ses clins
pour le moment les pourcentages qui sont
affichées ce sont des pourcentages en
cologne
parfois ce qu'on aimerait savoir d'où
petits pots de pourcentage sur les
pourcentages totaux soit des
pourcentages en ligne et on a le
paramètre personnes ce alors qu'un
paramètre globale qui permet d'indiquer
le type de pourcentage qui nous est pas
une épaulière
fonctionne est un paramètre global il
n'y a pas de formules et si je fais
personnes les galgos
je vais
à vous non
donc ici voyez on est maintenant sur des
pourcentages en ligne 46 54 % qui font
100 % enfin il ya une dernière option si
je vais sur tibial se marient dans fitch
et dead comparé à m persons
on a aussi celles ci on veut des
pourcentages totaux si je fais ici le
paramètre sel
si on fait le paramètre celle voyez on
est sur des pourcentages du total donc
12 et 14 qui vont faire 27% et tout ça
va s'additionner à 100%
alors je voyais de rapidement du côté
des questions certaines j'y répondrai
pas tout de suite parce qu'on va
l'aborder juste après donc vous ne vous
inquiétez pas
je vous une question de l'once est à
quoi c'est à l'argument bail je répète
l'argument bail permet de rajouter si un
tri sur traitement si je retire ce bail
là tu veux commenter la vie comme ça ne
sera pas tenue en route j'aurais
simplement une colonne on n'a pas deux
ados gaulle à dubaï si je ne mets pas de
colonne bail j'aurais simplement des
statistiques pour l'ensemble du fichier
donc le paramètre bail permet d'indiquer
que je souhaitais que mes statistiques
soient présentés par son groupe
une question
c'est peut-on avoir une feuille un
recteur de varia en option bye non il
n'est pas possible d'avoir un vecteur de
variables dans l'option bye bye ne peut
prendre qu'un seul vecteur
après il ya des manières
[Musique]
il ya des manières de procéder
alors attendre que l'exemple sa fiche
j'ai ralenti de verre c'est la captation
visuels qui nous ralentit
je demande quelques instants
je reprends
donc comme
le paramètre bail on peut pas mettre un
vecteur de variables après si je veux
croisés sur deux variables il est
possible de combiner
avec la fonction
interactions alors je vais prendre un
exemple
[Musique]
pour montrer l'exemple interactions
elle prend les données titanic
chez les charges exceptionnelles pour
chercher les données de h début 2003
vous connaissez normalement
si je vous montre à quoi ressemble hdv
les van dyck uni non comme par exemple
ce sport pratiqué du sport et puis si je
la variable
j'ai la variable sexe qui la variable
comme ça et je voudrais faire un tableau
qu'ils soient hommes qui font du sport
hommes qu'il faut pas de ce pain qui
font du sport
enfin nouveau pack sport et donc je peux
recréer recoder avec interaction
rapidement si je fais
hdv
2003 de la clé groupe
qui fait interactions de hdv 2003
sexe mais hdv
sport
ça va me créer une nouvelle variable ou
la demande tout de suite
quatre modalités donc action ça permet
de combiner deux vecteurs entre eux pour
faire toutes les combinaisons des deux
vecteurs donc là j'ai créé une variable
à
la de vecteurs et je peux maintenant si
je le souhaite
faire hdv 2003
un petit billet sommellerie
en fonction du gros
les jeux veut afficher
le nombre d'heures passées dans la
télévision donc heures point tv
et donc en faisant que ça
je vais présenter donc la leur mais le
nombre médian d'heures passées devant la
télévision pour chacun de mes quatre
groupes ce qui me permet de répondre à
une question posée par jamilloux c'est
que la variable katyn auriel de
l'argument bagne peut avoir plus de deux
modalités donc on peut faire en trois
groupes quatre groupes cinq groupes il
ya aucun souci
donc ramener bien à bail on doit passer
une seule variable mais on peut tout à
fait avec les techniques classiques de
reconnaître qu'on a vu en amont
représentait
plus précisément recoder et créer des
deux groupes en fonction des besoins
alors j'aime revenir sur un exemple de
tout à l'heure
donc je vais repartir de churn
j'ai fait un petit billet elle se marie
dans quel jeu les m
h
parce que si grave
ont varié le faire bail à l'ostal itx
mais je vais afficher les satistiques
différentes pour l'ag pour marqueur
d'accord statistiques
je vais pour l'âge je vais afficher
l'âge médian mais il a pas mal
interquartile
donc je vais indiquer
médiane
mais puis-je voile un terrain fertile
qu'indiqué entre crochets gauches que
j'ai décidé que serait un crochet dont
25 comme une carte il
et 75
pour le 2ème bertil mai puis du coup
pour la variable marca je vais faire la
moyenne
avec l'écart type
entre parenthèses
les en dessous 1
donc vous voyez là j'ai bien représentée
ici médiane avec
media l'intervalle interquartile et puis
marqueur avec la moyenne les quartiers
alors en bas âge ou vendre la petite
note tout ce que nous présente c'est la
médiane entre crochets car type la
moyenne entre parenthèses
médiane entre crochets intervalles est
infertile moyenne entre parenthèses
l'écart type et puis les effectifs pour
les pourcentages mais c'est pas
forcément facile à l'est puisque honda
qu'une note de la tâche qui est globale
et donc du coup ce qu'on voudrait c'est
d'afficher le type de statistiques donc
faire dans une 2 du tableau mais plutôt
à côté de chacune des variables
pour ça je peux appliquer la fonction
a des stats label
mais si j'applique la fonction
had stats la
bng puma note de bas de page par contre
le type de statistiques est indiquée à
côté du nom de la variable donc à y
envoyer à marquer h virgule médiane et
quartier marqueur level virgule moyenne
écart type grad virgule haine pour sont
plutôt que de le mettre à côté du nom la
variable mais plutôt d'avoir nicolon
dédié on peut aussi modifier ici en
indiquant locale il ya
colonnes
et dans ce cas là on a une nouvelle
colonne bielle s'appelle ici
statistiques donc j'ai une colonne avec
le nom de la variable et j'ai ensuite
une colonne statistiques qui nous
indique qu est-ce qui est représenté
donc c'est une manière aussi d'avoir des
choses qui sont plus faciles et plus
visible
et plus facile à voir
alors et je crois que ça va à
répondre à une des questions qui nous
aller qui est posée par l'un d'entre
vous il est possible de forcer le tic
d'une variable
donc je vais reprendre un exemple
si je fais tes valises son mari et que
j'inclus uniquement la variable âge
donc la variable âge c'est une variable
numérique ici donc à présent qui a plus
de dix modalités est donc détecter et
traiter par défaut comme variable
continu et donc ce qui représentait
c'est la médiane avec l'intervalle
interquartile mais le paramètre titre
va permettre de forcer le type de
marianne alors je vais vous proposer un
exemple un peu plus complet
partons de la variable âge de la
variable at il à marianne baisse
donc pour rappel la bible âge et
détecter automatiquement comme étant du
type continue la variable grave qui a
plusieurs facteurs est détecté comme
dernière catégorielles et personnes
daikin variable de type 0 1 au queen on
est traité comme variable catégorielles
dichotomique et je peux changer le type
de ces différentes variables par exemple
je vais dire titre
je vais indiquer que je veux que h soit
traitée comme une variable catégorielles
donc type 4 go oublie qu
est par exemple je vais dire que je
souhaite que duff
soit traitée comme une variable continu
avec continue hausse
si je ça
vous voyez la jce y est traitée comme
une verrue catégorielles donc j'ai un
tableau d'un tri à plat des valeurs
d'agen tout simplement qu'ils seront
compris dans ce fichier et puis pêcheurs
de taiji une médiane et un intervalle
interquartile il j'ai forcé un
traitement continu et du coup tu es flat
est traitée comme une variable de type
donc il a calculé une médiane et de
moyenne j'aurais aussi pu dire que jeff
je veux le traité en catégorique
donc j'aurai du coup au lieu d'avoir un
pourcentage de patients qui sont décédés
j'aurai deux pourcentages et puis
j'aurais bien aussi traiter variable
wade comme une variable
dichotomique
alors la partie et ses comptes j'ai une
variable qui n'est pas connu oui non que
je veux qu'elle soit traitée comme
dichotomique il faut jeunes indique
quelles sont
les valeurs la valeur a affiché quel est
parmi toutes les valeurs qui sont la 1 2
et 3 laquelle je vais afficher donc
supposons je veux fichiers uniquement
les gens de grade 3
il faut que j'indique comme value
donc pour brigitte la valeur à retenir
tournon waldighoffen hic c'est à dire
celles que la valeur que je vais retenir
c'est uniquement un valeur 3
donc là
l'âge
la variable âge est toujours traitée en
catégorique la variable jeff est traitée
en catégorie les dangers les dolines et
l'élite en fait il m'affiche uniquement
les valeur égale à 3 alors bien sûr
comme il me met que l'étiquette de la
variable c'est pas forcément visibles et
j'aurais peut-être intérêt ici à
modifier on n'a pas encore vu mais c'est
la belle qui permet ça permet de changer
l'étiquette d'une variable pour dire oui
2 3 et avoir du coup quelque chose de
plus explicite
alors j'en profite du coup pour voir une
autre astuce de t-bills à marie
c'est je vous le dis on a des variables
catégorielles dichotomique qui est un
sous type de 1re catégorie et là
seulement de modalités on elle va le
type continue et en fait on a un autre
type un peu particulier qu'est le type
continue ce tout et ce type là en fait
c'est une astuce pour indiquer des
variables dont on souhaite que les
résultats soient représentées sur
plusieurs lignes c'est un titre de
l'ariane et
ça va répondre à une des questions qui
nous étaient posées par jamioulx sur
espionner la possibilité de calculer la
moyenne d'un quartier d'une part et un
média ne les cuirs d'autres pas
alors
je vais revenir ici
on va partir avec deux variables de
départ donc j'ai présenté les âges et
mark hurd le variable continu
l'indiqué que ces deux variables là
alors je peux refaire ma sélection
pareil l'accès à the marker pour dire
ces deux variables là
je veux qu'elle soit considérée comme du
type continue
la particularité c'est que les variables
de type continue ce 2e but est pour a
indiqué à satistiques plusieurs lignes
de statistiques
donc ici dans satistiques je l'indiquais
rôle
continu os tout
et vous devenez juste une valeur perçue
alors emmené plusieurs
donc j'ai ordonné 3g par exemple dire je
veux déjà affiché
la médiane
et puis en rempl aise
et 25 dans le premier quartile et 75 le
troisième carte il donc j'ai mon intérêt
certes il
et puis je voudrais sur une autre ligne
indiqué
la moyenne
et l'écart type
le titre
royer les mégane sur la même ligne bien
de mal interdit c'est juste ce soit fait
pas sens du point de vue statique et
puis enfin j'aurais bien afficher le
minimum et maximum on va afficher le
mini max
vous voyez pour des variables qui
continue se continue ce tout on peut
fournir non pas une ligne de stats mais
plusieurs faveur de statistiques et
voyez comment ça se présente
ce que j'ai ici eh bien je vais avoir
une mini ferme pour chacun des éléments
statistiques il a tout de suite il
remplace il détecte médias et 25 et 20
75 pour proposer un affichage
cohérent mais voyez j'ai bien
l'affichage des médianes de la moyenne
et de l'étendue minimum maximum donc
c'est vraiment les avantages de
continuer ce 2 c'est quand on a
plusieurs variables qui sont de type
continue on peut gérer ça et si je
rajoute ou bien comprendre rajouter une
troisième marque continue tu l'aidés
f.pdf je n'ai pas dit quel était le type
continue ce de dompter def va être
affichés comme variable continu
classique elle est pas impactés par
cette fille là pour t'aider j'aurais
juste simplement
l'affichage par défaut qui aimait diana
intervalle interverti
les voyez on a une grande possibilité
pour mettre en forme nos résultats
alors on va partir d'un tableau un peu
simple pour voir comment on peut
personnaliser aussi le nombre de
décimales qui sont affichées je vais
repartir lente et demi alors oui
on va afficher
h
avant pour le franglais en fonction du
traitement
donc si je vous représente ceci
par défaut en fait jetty se met lui
essaye de trouver un nombre de décimales
appropriée a présenté
alors tombé juste avant les mêmes
questions
[Musique]
et nous voulons la somme et bien si vous
avez la somme il vous fera suffit de
rajouter
si la somme
son exemple d'avant las fait partie en
fait des fonctions
dont on peut calculer une statistique
pour toutes les vagues continue en fait
vous pouvez appeler toutes les fonctions
qu'ils prennent un vecteur et vous
renvoie de valeur unique les loyers que
là
vous avez la somme qu'ils affichaient
leurs petites précisions sur la somme là
s'est pas traduit parfois certaines
fonctions qui ne sont pas traduites ça
déjà été signalés çà sera traduit dans
la prochaine version de tutu se marient
mais vous inquiétez pas un parfois il ya
certaines fonctions qui détecte pas et
dont il n'assure pas encore la
traduction mais h 10 sam à lui évolué de
manière assez continue et c'est quelque
chose qui va arriver d'ici peu mais pour
le coup ça a déjà été corrigé dans la
match de l'euro alors
et avant son exemple d'avant puisque je
vois que une chose bertin épouse depuis
savez profond que la marque y sont
opposés comment procéder la
stratification d'un tableau croisé avec
pas et sans faire intervenir
interactions vous créez simplement la
variable adéquat toutes les modalités de
reco d'âge pour créer une variable avec
plusieurs groupes et vous appliquez
cette variable interactions c'est qu'un
exemple et pour savoir comment faire un
reportage de marianne catégorielles je
vous invite à revoir les premiers
mobiles
alors je reviens à cet exemple vous avez
deux variables de représenter une
barrière continue quel âge daria
catégorielles qui est stage est par
défaut
donc jti smaoui essaye de trouver part
variable le bon nombre adéquat de
chiffres après la virgule représentés
mais souvent ça correspond pas forcément
l'as roma en vie et c'est là que le
paramètre dj va être intéressant parce
qu'il va nous permettre d'indiquer le
nombre de
décimales a représenté par exemple je
pourrais dire dit [ __ ] me calme
alors
soit je me dire partout je peux utiliser
une fine pour dire pour toutes les
variables et je vais indiquer un
faisant ça vous voyez que toutes les
vannes à part les effectifs de manquant
toutes les variables maintenant sont
présentés avec une décimale et vous le
film me dire pour toutes les variables
il faut savoir qu'une manière d'écrire
cet impact sur un peu plus simple c'est
de ne rien mettre à gauche dit il devant
mais rien à gauche utile on comprend que
ça veut dire pour toutes les variables
après là on voit que peut-être qu'on a
un affichage qui serait un petit peu
différent à utiliser pour nos variable
continu et une au barrio catégorie mg
faire du compte le temps est un petit
peu je veux pour les variables continue
donc pour les variables continue si je
mets un seul chiffre donc ça va
appliquer aux trois statistiques
représenter je vous rappel pour les
variables continue actuellement présente
une médiane un premier kart il est un
troisième quart tiennent donc on
représente trois statistiques si je met
uniquement un ça va s'appliquer à tous
je peux aussi donner des valeurs
différentes si je fais 2 1 1 john dit
que je veux que la première statistique
soit affichée avec deux décimales et que
les deux autres soient affichés avec une
seule dessina
est par exemple je pourrais dire que
pour les variables catégorique
une fois ci représentent 2 satisfait
qu'on a un effectif suivi d'un
pourcentage à l'effectif en général on a
vraiment un fichier de décimales mais
pour le pourcentage là j'aimerais bien
avoir une décimale donc j'ai indiqué
c'est 0-1
et ça me permet d'afficher a donc
d'afficher les effectifs arrondi à
l'unité aimé de pourcentage avait un
chiffre
il ya une question qui était posée pour
savoir qu'elle est l'astuce utilisée
pour exécuter un ensemble des lignes
sans les sélectionnés
alors je vous renvoie tout début juin
sur comment fonctionnent
les studios dans les studios vous avez
ici wayne
et on peut réaliser run directement avec
contrôle entre et c'est ce que j'utilise
tout le temps en fait je tape sur mon
clavier contrôle entre et je suis sur
windows ça serait peut rentrer sous mac
et donc contre l'entrée ça veut dire
exécuter la ligne en cours
la particularité c'est que là les lignes
de code voiliers sont entourés
parenthèse démis qu'ils ont pas fini et
donc du coup r si je comprends que quand
je suis là je suis à l'intérieur de
toute cette commande là et donc si je me
situe ici quelques contrôles entre et
voyez il transmet bien l'ensemble du
bloc de cottignies fiant à et c'est la
fac de taper ça se passe de manière
propre d'avoir les pailles en fin de
ligne les parenthèses en fin de ligne ce
qui fait que cette ligne là on se doute
bien que se poursuit sur la suite et
donc dans ce cas là hadji qui l'a studio
des thèmes bien tout seul le bloc
decottignies fientes un contrôle entre
et on envoie directement ce code de
glock directement à la console
concernant
on a vu ici gibbs on a aussi une
possibilité qui est d'indiquer une
fonction pour la mise en forme
alors c'est un petit peu subtil on le
verra peut-être plus tard mais plutôt
que de mettre ici un nombre d'accords ce
que l'on peut mettre est une fonction
qui formate un nombre est une fonction
qui formate à nombre
on l'avait déjà abordé avec number et la
belle amber d'accord une fonction qui
formate un nombre
c'est
vous sont détaillés et il ya un nouveau
paragraphe qui a été mis en ligne sur
sur un analyseur donc je vais vous le
présentez
le temps de revenir la
nature bon écran
on va aller sur le site analyseur
sur le analyser à vous avez d'en
approfondir le chapitre mettre en forme
des nombres avec skyrock c'est quelque
chose qu'on avait déjà abordé aussi avec
les graphiques parce que gégé pelote à
plein d'endroits a besoin de fonctions
qui met en forme dénombre donc je vais
revenir je vous représenter au moins le
début mais sachez qu'il ya un chapitre
entier sur ce sujet là d'accord donc
par défaut il ya juste deux trois
fonctions qui sont fournies par avis qui
sera lui qui sont stijnen d'un style
personnes style des rallyes austin si
les styles ratio qui correspond à une
mise en forme de nombre mais si on va
aller plus loin il faut partir sur le
package à ce qu'ils
étaient il faut bien comprendre la
différence entre la fonction under
et la fonction le label number la
fonction number c'est la fonction de
base pour la mise en forme de nombre
dans ce qu'il
on va lui donner une série de noms par
exemple je vais dire
0.2 point
5.54 et 10 points
et ça va le meules mettre en ondes et je
peux modifier alors dans number on
n'indique pas le nombre de décimales on
indique le niveau de précision c'est à
quel endroit on s'en va agrandir ou si
je fais à keolis il ya point 0,1 en
avons dit au point 0,01 le plus proche
ont complètement présente deux décimales
mais j'aurais pu dire points points 25
et donc dans ce cas là on arrondit au
0,25 le plus proche
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
number c'est une fonction qui prend des
nombres et les maires forme
mais donc ce renvoi number ce sont des
nombres mis en forme
et c'est là où par endroits souvent les
fonctions pour les échelles angers
compte ici dans dj tz6 hall il m a dit
si bâle en matière de fonctions qui
formate à la fois son influence et de
nos fonctions et c'est là où vous avez
label d'albert alors si vous regardez
les deux labels bamba
c'est exact les mêmes options que nomba
s'offrir x label numbers est une
fonction qui va renvoyer une fonction
qui va mettre en forme les nombres
alors je m'explique supposons que
j'avais une fonction qui arrondissent
avec deux décimales de la pf deux
d'accord je vais appeler la belle amber
donc moi je veux que ça rebondisse avec
deux décimales à que les
60.8 rendu utilise comme séparateur un
aller 1-5 ont changé plutôt fines bulles
je veux que mon séparateur de décimales
fassois intiale
label même peur ici va renvoyer une
fonction est donc cette nouvelle
fonction j'avais là stop dans un f2 et
maintenant je pourrais faire f 2 du
chiffre
je peux lui m utilise ses fonctions pour
mettre en forme le chiffre le nombre 12e
24 56 qui va être mis en forme selon ce
que j'ai envoyé ici donc là les
fonctions dans ce qu'est l'os qui
s'appelle la belle
en fait vous renvoyer une fonction
customiser
ça renvoie pas d'ennemis en forme ça
renvoie une fonction qu'il est en forme
et c'est ça qui va être attendu
dans le paramètre dis vite c'est-à-dire
qu'elle dit gypse je pouvais lui passer
une fonction qui va mettre enfants
alors vous avez label nalbert ce qui est
intéressant aussi c'est que vous avez
dont on nomme beurre
je vous avez aussi la possibilité si
vous avez inscrit par une multiplication
par quelque chose par exemple pour
représenter quelque chose en pour mille
et l'appel aux morts
alors je les affiches et avec une
précision
au point mais si mal j'applique à parme
et esquire et mieux c'est à dire
multiplient ce nom par 1000 pour me
l'affiché mais je peux indiquer un
suffixe
on peut faire un symbole pour me
normalement je m'en souvenir jamais du
symbole pour mille
[Musique]
je voulais retrouver il doit être
le symbole pour millet la
cu 20 30
donc si
quelque chose
c'est pour
ce qu'ils affichaient après notre pour
ajouter à ou non mis en forme mais
maintenant si je fais pour mille
e
je sais que la moins de 0,25
savent afficher 254 8 pour mille j'écris
une fonction qui multiplie par mille
affiches avec avec une décimale et nous
rajoute le symbole pour mir
et donc du coup je pourrais utiliser
ces fonctions là
ici je pourrais dire que je voudrais que
utiliser la fonction
f2 uci et la fonction pour mille ici
m à la place de m une valeur numérique
je peux mettre une fonction qui met en
forme
par compte voyez il ya 1 % qui arrivera
ou faut que je les fasse il ya des
petites choses qu'à faire comme ça mais
je peux on va faire
satistiques
on continue ce hall catégorie col pardon
elle n'en
est donc je supprime pour sont ici parce
qu il m a ajouté il va être ajoutée par
ma fonction pour bill
qu'elle a eues
mais voyez on a les possibilités pour
aller très loin dans la mise en forme
alors je voulais montrer ici pour ça
pour vous sachez que ça existe dans la
plupart des cas vous aurez juste besoin
de vous occuper de change et non de
décimales essayez pas d'aller trop loin
il n'y a pas besoin de s'occuper plus
avant que ça mais il ya moyen de
personnaliser de manière très forte
c'est comme tout ce qu'on a vu par le
passé
dans la plupart des cas essayez
d'utiliser les fonctionnalités par
défaut mais sachez que au besoin d'un
moyen d'aller sur des fonctionnalités
avancées
lorsque c'est nécessaire
alors je crois qu'une des questions qui
étaient posées
c'était comment enlever les données
manquantes de l'analyse alors c'est
effectivement une bonne question on va
repartir
sur un exemple
pour l'homme
tibi elle se marie et moi je fais venir
floute égale
h
je vais rajouter quelque chose de valeur
manquant qui est grave
on a à m qui avec me signe
qui indique si jamais il faut afficher
ou non les valeurs mon compte donc par
défaut voyez les valeurs manquantes sont
affichés seulement s'il y en a qui n'ont
pas de valeurs manquantes et du coup ils
sont pas affichés
vous avez ce paramètre me simca
paramètres globale donc comme tara
mcdonald ou
pas
il ya deux
de thil d'une formule 1 si on donne
josiane pour la valeur vous avez au
louise option pour dire je veux
systématiquement voir le nombre de
valeurs manquantes
qu'il y en ait au qu'il y en ait pas ça
rajoute et du coup ces équipements comme
zéro pour great où vous pouvez indiquer
une eau
il vous ne riez pas de valeur mais korpi
précision si vous mettez un paramètre by
les valeurs manquantes sur le paramètre
buy seront systématiquement supprimés
par contre si vous voulez les affiches
et ça sera vous en amont de dire que
c'est madame hank rhon voulant faire une
catégorie à part et en tant que tel et
je vous rappelle la fonction qui permet
sa cft explicite énarque de forgan on
avait déjà vu dans un certain nombre de
figures
abordons maintenant rapidement la
question des étiquettes de variables
si vous né il est possible d'en airs
d'un ticket des étiquettes de variables
et d'associer du coup une étiquette à
chacune des variables et on avait vu ça
ça se fait que l'on peut le faire
notamment avec le match là bells avec la
fonction par la belle ou la fonction
cette variable
supposons qu'on ait
maigri je vous remonte comme iris 1
c'est un
tableau de bonnet qui est beaucoup
utilisant les exemples on va faire un
look fort sur iris
il est composé de quatre variable
continu et de trois variables et d'une
variable pardon facteur à trois
modalités ce jeu donnait iris il est
toujours présent dans l'air et par
défaut il n'ya pas d'étiquette de
variables donc si je fais un petit bl so
mairie
sur ce jeu de benêt
comme il n'ya pas d'étiquette de
variables ce que va utiliser comme nom
de varier ce que va utiliser jetty
sommellerie commande variable se sont
allés nom des colonnes proprement
on peut tout à fait avec la belle de
définir des étiquettes de variables
avec la fonction cette variable à belz
donc là je le fais à la volée je
sauvegarde pas dans l'église mais je
pourrais dire que métal
fin l'étiquette qui serait longueur
du pétale
et p table pour le whif
qu'israël largeur
pesant avouez du coup les portes des
étiquettes qui sont dans mon jeu de
donner ce que je peux faire mettre
plusieurs avant et sauvegarder le
résultat donc je donnais un cpe même
s'il ya des étiquettes de variables
elles vont directement et de prise en
compte par ge qui sert à lui on peut
enfin également indiqué des étiquettes
d'antibes ya selon lui avec la belle
donc là on est dans tibet le se marient
donc c'est toujours nombre variable
tilde mais je le plains par exemple
jeudi pour species
pile d'
espèce je peux aussi écraser une
variable d génétiques et des valeurs
harper calvaire
va nous donner une étiquette
on voyait les valeurs qui est dans la
paire sont reprises ici avec une
étiquette espèces c'est à dire que ce
que l'on passe pour paramètres label
d'antibes elle se marie à la priorité
signe un
s'il n'y a pas les modalités
alors on va aller voir
s'il n'ya pas du coup les modalités on
va aller voir s'il ya des étiquettes de
variables et s'il n'y a pas des clips de
variables on prendra le nom des
variables pour rappel les étiquettes de
darial on peut les voir avec l'eau fort
si je vous fais surtout à niort
le coup fort vous voyez qu'il ya des
étiquettes de variables 1 c'est là que
la belle associés à chacune des
variables et puis
si vous appliquez un view pour voir le
visualiseur de données de l'étude you
les étiquettes ne variable vous voyez
sont également directement indiqué ici
dans le tableau
alors je vois une question qui nous est
posée donc jérémy un tout petit pas en
arrière c'est par rapport aux
variablement compte qu'ils étaient est
ce qu'il est possible de prendre en
compte les n'a comme modalité de calcul
des proportions pour les variables cali
alors on va prendre un exemple
je vais créer un
mais revenir ici supposons donc
lingettes gels iris je vais me faire un
saut de créer des valeurs manquantes
je crée un objet thème et par an qui va
être le cas de louis vi
et dans species je vais créer je vais
dire qu'ils les valeurs manquantes je
vais prendre les 5 premières heures leur
appliquer un être
donc
je fais iris
sait mais elle se met au lit
pour la variable uniquement lorsqu'il
species
cmp
a changé si je prends le tableau pmp
j'ai simplement quand d'accord donc les
pourcentages sont calculés manquant
exclu on suppose que je veut inclure ces
bonnes et aimant compte dans mon calcul
du pourcentage
faire ça ça revient à considérer que
nouvelle rn à d'accord sont des valeurs
amont explicite et on peut tout à fait
transformer les valeurs manquantes ont
une valeur explicite
alors je vais faire ici je vais créer
une variable que je vais appeler ce
qu'elle 6 2
et donc j'ai partir de species
je veux lui appliquer la fonction vous
ai paniqué fc pts et explicite henin
sauf que pour ça il me faut le taille
diverse que je n'ai pas de charge en
mémoire on va le faire
maintenant j'ai le talent diverses
formes et moi donc je vais appliquer ici
excepté explicite n1
indiqué anna level bon analysé j'ai
appelé ça manque en
vue donc ma variable et 6 2 c'est comme
la variable species sauf qu'il ya une
quatrième modalités
la trois là c'est au sein versicolor
virginie cas et mon camp
si du coup dans mon tableau je me
représente les 2
moi j'avais fait leur stade
yves
sélectionner les peuls un pont
voyez que pour species gdn a qui sont
considérés comme manquants les
pourcentages sont calculées hors acp
pour species 2g nouvelles modalités qui
s'appelle manquant donc c'est une
modalité en soi et donc du coup il est
inclus dans le calcul et pourcentage
l'âge et 30 % en trente trois 33 et 3,3
pour cent
alors on va revenir maintenant à
quelques petits loups outils qui vont
permettre d'améliorer le rendu de
tableau je vais repartir de royal
fait refaire
tableau alors là pour le coup je
présente mais simplement de variable
continue sur ma wii on va présenter
icloud
âge et marc hein
ça nous présentant comme on l'a vu par
défaut donc la médiane internat terres
fertiles j'ai simplement envie de
rajouter dans mon tableau les effectifs
et ça peut se faire en une colonne grand
peine 15 des effectifs
je peux avoir des effectifs part
variable directement avec à la haine la
fonction adn permet de rajouter une
colonne
avec les effectifs tout haut
on va voir plus loin donc là ce qu'on
veut ce que je vais refaire dans mon
tableau
je vais reprendre ici
la fiche du coup les variables âge les
marqueurs j'ai regardé leurs données en
fonction de la crds et mans et on va
masquer pour bambins
données manquantes
donc quand je fais ça
j'aime invariable haine qui m'indique
juste le nom de valeur totale
mais on peut personnaliser
le rendu
donc
pour revoir toutes les options de l'adn
le mieux c'est d'aller regarder l'aide
at elle poursuivi elle se marie pas ce
que vous avez tous les éléments qui sont
là mais on va voir que dans les
personnalisations je peux modifier la
statistique
chez
jeudi les statistiques
et on peut avoir notamment fait petit
end sont les effectifs observé mais j'ai
aussi grand peine le nombre total
d'observation donc je pourrais avoir
tout simplement
représenter le nom de l'observation
valide petites haines et le nombre
d'observations total
je peux personnaliser
l'étiquette de la colonne avec code
label
donc je vais chez déjà mettre en gras
doubles étoiles
effectif
et là je vais retirer le gras
observez
donc si je fais ça
j'ai même ri j'ai changé l'intitulé de
la colonne et j'ai bien 189 observations
sur deux sont au total 197 sa ration
mali sur de son on peut aussi mettre la
colonne si on veut à la fin avec last il
ya le fond
je peux et me dire je veux aussi qu'ils
notent
le tableau avec votre club légal chiu
et voiliers là alors il ya un petit
souci traduction mais pareil la
traduction française était incomplète
dans la version actuelle cela sera
corrigé dans la prochaine et vous voyez
on a une note de bas de page le tableau
apparente note de tableau qui a été
rajoutée pour cette colonne effectif et
c est maintenant présenté à la fin du
tableau
[Applaudissements]
on va voir aussi qu'on a quelques
possibilités additionnelles pour mettre
en forme notre tableau donc on va
repartir sur un autre exemple en haut je
vais faire un petit billet elle
se marie
alors on va faire un petit mix de
variables
allez on va mettre âge
grade
stage pendant quelques variables aussi
catégorielles on va présenter ses
instructions de tels traitements
et qu'on te dit qu'il pourrait être
intéressant de rôle de tableau un peu
plus lisible il est notamment possible
de mettre en gras les noms des variables
donc ça se fait que la fonction bold la
health
mettre en garde les variables les jeunes
cygnes fonctions it and a sigh ce level
ce qui va mettre en et techniques les
niveaux vous aurez remarqué qu'il ya
aussi une fonction au pôle de
gouvernance et une fonction i télé size
label sera tout ce qui est à portée de
main mais si je fais ça je vais changer
un peu la mise en forme du tableau
voyez les étiquettes ici des modalités
sont mises en italique et j'ai mis sur
tous les noms de variables en grâce qui
rend les choses un petit peu plus
alors
on va continuer dans la personnalisation
de nos tableaux et on va voir comment
est-ce qu'on peut modifier les en tête
de colonne et comment est-ce qu'on peut
aussi modifier
la formule de notes de bas de page
déjà j'avais commencé à refaire un
tableau
on pourra partir de troll
de faire pipi samarie
bon
on va prendre à les
ipod
et puis éventuellement on va compliquer
un tout petit peu notre tableau
avec
pauvres
est ce que je vais faire je les
sauvegarder mon tableau dans un objet
comment
donc je prends au lieu des fichiers mon
tableau je peux le prendre et se
regarder tout ça dans un objet tv
l'intérêt c'est qu'en faisant ça
voilà
vous st
on va voir comment est-ce qu'on peut
changer d en tête de colonne mais pour
ça il faut connaître le nom des colonnes
en fait les connaissons un nom de code
en interne mais on peut le voir avec la
fonction chaud
ni leur lines le tibia qui permet
d'afficher le nom des différentes
colonnes
ce qu'on voit c'est qu'en fait la
colonne qui contient
les noms de varia elle s'appelle
l'appelle la colonne du bas et ses stats
1 et stade 2 et la colonne stade zéro
c'est la commune général du à dogo
ce qui va ici nous intéresser ça va être
de pouvoir
modifier
les en tête de colonne j'avais pour
comprendre
je vais partir de tvn vraiment à notre
dame de fer un mot l'ifa leader
et je faire emmener par étapes
le principe c'est qu'à modified là on va
dire qu'elle est la colonne qu'est ce
qu'on veut à la place
d'accords dont je les passais une liste
de modifications
je veux dire déjà que la colonne
vous voyez ici un petit égalise vous
avez la stat qui est là donc je vais
faire modify leader ici il ya liste
avec le double tarentaise est ce qu'on
voit là premiers éléments que je vais
changer c'est la belle
et je vais dire que l'impasse aux
caractéristiques moi ce que j'aimerais
c'est marc est variable
si je fais ce tableau là et je suis
lasse impact qu'on m'a suggéré ici
ça m'affiche tout simplement mariage
j'ai mis à jour cette colonne ce que
j'aimerais c'est pour aussi modifié
à
la présentation des colonnes à la jack
hayes rugby
d'accord mais j'ai mannone faire ça une
fois tout en tenant compte des effectifs
alors ce qu'on peut faire que tout que
dire stat 1 et stade 2 il ya un
sélecteur qui s'appelle allstate kohl's
d'accord qui va sélectionner toutes les
colonnes qui compte par stadler score
donc là ça me prendrait 1 2 et 0 et j'ai
une option dedans qu'il dira stade zéro
femmes c'est pour dire je veux tout les
colonnes ce pacte sauf la colonne stade
zéro
et là je vais indiquer ce que je veux un
fichier l'intérêt c'est qu'en fait pour
ces colonnes la qui sont les colonnes
d'un bail j'ai accès à deux variables
lune qui est levée
et l'autre qui est n et pnc le
n ça correspond à un nombre
d'observations et baisser le pourcentage
dans l'élément donc là par exemple je
vais lire j'aimerais affiché que ce soit
leven
chez l'étiquette se jouera du grain je
mettrai des doubles étoiles là
j'aimerais juste de l'italie donc jamais
des étoiles simple on cotise des thunder
score aussi
bref échange entre parenthèses le petit
nom jédir n égale entre accolade n c'est
pour dire
mais je vais afficher le pourcentage
virgules et là je veux affiché un
pourcentage le trou et c'est que si je
mets pays pour cent
alors qu'est ce que j'ai fait
l'alimentaire gulli psy op
il est ici payez en fait ça contient de
pourcentage mais brut 0,49 0,51 donc je
peux mettre entre les accolades je peux
même mettre une fonction donc j'utilise
et still here cents le p
ici ma colonne a été
personnalisé en indiquant non seulement
l'effectif mais le pourcentage leurs
voisins de boeck a dans le total
vous voyez avec modified on peut aller
assez loin sur ce qu'on veut faire
retenez aussi que vouloir en faire de
trop ça prend du temps de retrouver
toutes les petites astuces mais on peut
aller très loin dans la personnalisation
pour jour dans la personnalisation vous
avez modify un
autre note qui permet de modifier une
note de bas de page et notamment où
pourrait dire je veux les supprimer les
supprimer ce serait du coup les rangs
passé par rien n a bougé faire et racing
tilde
à et ça me permet de supprimer mes notes
de bas de page
et puis éventuellement on peut vouloir
faire
une colonne dur de chaque pot en fait on
appelle ça un staline leader en anglais
sur le chapeau qui va regrouper à
différentes variables s'appelle modify
les
leaders
mais je vais dire quels sont les
barrières que je veut regrouper
l'ensemble je prends pas pareil mais
c'est ici pas de colonne sauf 7 0
je fais une donne que je vais appeler
traitement je m'attends gras donc nulle
et one
mais voyez ça m'a fait ça m'a regrouper
ces deux créneaux bien ça m'a rajouté un
chapeau ici
vous avez des options qui vous permette
d'aller assez loin
dans la personnalisation du tableau
et qui sont fournis il ya vraiment moyen
de faire tous les tableaux tel qu'on le
veuille vraiment un résultat final
alors on va aborder quand même quelques
avantages que faire
avec
avec tibet elle se marie pour aller plus
un peu plus loin notamment avec des
zones comparaison est affichée l'épée
valeur de ces tests de comparaison
et on verra après comment la lie sur des
intervalles de confiance donc pour des
tests de comparaison
il est impératif d'avoir utilisé
fonction gbagbo gérard tir
d'un tableau
avec plusieurs variables et rebuy
donc ici on va prendre
pertes et
marqueurs
h
en fonction de traitement
vous êtes chauffer blue
et maintenant devrait du coup comparer
est ce que le niveau de marqueurs est
différent entre la colonne à et la
colonne b est-ce que l'âge est différent
ou pas c'est ici qu'entre les
entre les deux colonnes
pour cela d'accord et est ce que
la répartition de tester va être
différente entre les deux groupes
alors pour ça on va faire un pige
la fonction l'acpi ci est variable
paille doit permettre de faire de
calculer la paix valeur d'un test de
comparaison des deux variables la
variable bail est la variable qui en
gros pour savoir qu'il est le test qu'il
calculait par défaut vous l'avez ici en
bas un la petite note et là on voit que
les deux hôtesses utilisées par défaut
c'était le tese gris coxon man whitney
et le test du kit d'indépendance le
teaser louis coxon mcnutt n'est ce qu'un
thèse ou comparaison des médianes sa
thèse de somme des rangs mais qui permet
de comparer des médianes et vous avez
ensuite le test du kilo d'indépendance
qui permet de croiser les coupes de vin
la catégorie b
pour y voir un peu plus clair en fait
c'est qu'il ya pas mal de places ceux
qui sont disponibles
si je fais appeler tibial sommellerie
pour le paramètre test il nous renvoie
vers une page documentation délier et on
voit tout la liste des tests qui sont
possibles pour tibial sa maman alors
c'est à vous de savoir quel est le bon
test à utiliser de manière générale ce
qu'il faut retenir c'est que normalement
par défaut
le test qui est utilisée c'est le ts de
cruscades malisse a pour comparer des
variables continue donc on tient trop
quatre modalités le test de trucs à
wallis et le test qui va permettre
d'aller faire une comparaison des
médianes d'un peu poussé sauf si les
variables bahia deux de niveau auquel
cas on est sur la théorie coxon qui
permet aussi comparer les médias ce cas
retenir c'est que c'est
où ils coxon n'est valable que pour
comparer de mediène alors que le test
crucial des relais vont comparer trois
ou quatre c'est pour ça qu'on bascule
sur ce test là par défaut et puis par
défaut c'est un truc idiot qui utilisait
pour comparer deux variables
catégorielles sauf quand il ya des élus
sont effectifs théoriques qui est
inférieur à 1 5 go quelqu'un a testé
fischer est plutôt utilisé donc j'ai dit
se marient essaye de trouver le bon
terme approprié suivant le type de
variables mais on peut tout à fait
choisir que précisément le test quand
utilisé au cas par cas
oui notamment supposons en fait qu'en
terme de statistiques
je décide que pour les variables
continue
d'en présenter plutôt la moyenne et
l'écart type
dans ce cas là ce qui serait plus
pertinent tests de comparaison c'est
d'avoir pour les variables continuera t
de comparaison de moyenne ce qui serait
dans ce cas là le test t2 sud enfin
mouloud est l'outil test donc du coup si
je faisais
ce choix-là d'afficher les thèses de
moyenne eh bien j'ai indiquerait que
pour les variables continue je voudrais
plutôt utilisé un test des 2 sud est
donc les médias n'est point un test mais
donc c'est à vous
alors qu'est ce qui ne marche pas
ce qui n'est pas content il me manque
une virgule l aide voilà
donc c'est à vous de vous assurer que
les tests que vous calculez sont
cohérents et c'est ici que vous affichez
les valeurs par des trous
les valeurs par défaut le petit somalie
elles sont cohérentes par défaut
représente une médias dont la thèse de
comparaison mediène
j'ai oublié j'ai pas mis les accolades
ou qui n'affiche pas la moyenne
mais si nous faisons le choix de
représenter des moyennes essayez plutôt
d'affiché du cou à la thèse de
comparaison de moyenne c'est à vous de
vous assurer qu'il ya une cohérence
entre les statistiques et fichiers et
les tests de comparaison
les thèses stud's et hôtesses qui est le
plus approprié ce qu'on voit ici c'est
que vous avez une une note de tableau un
peu général qui vous dit les tests
employés
mais sans vous dire l'image qu'elle sait
quoi elle teste donc envie de savoir ce
que vous faites on peut améliorer sa
grâce à la fonction c'est pareil
et footnote
et quand on applique la fonction
separate ce
pays footnote à ce moment là vous avez à
voir ici
deux variables différentes le test le
thé et le test du kit 2 avec notre deux
et trois et on vous a dit pour chacune
des valeurs qu'elle est là le test
utilisé
retenez que de manière générale la
manière dont les valeurs sont
représentés par be qui se marient dépens
de leurs valeurs pour l'été valeurs qui
sont supérieures à
20% des réserves au 2 août représente
qu'une seule des six magne et puis on va
avoir plus des 6 mars que l'était
d'ailleurs son plus petit et on est en
dessous des 25 01 12 qui représentait
et puis quand on va aller un peu plus
loin on va avoir des rôles ou 0,02 par
exemple mais quand c'est encore plus
petit on va avoir un pays on va avoir un
symbole inférieur qui représentait alors
la fonction qui ne
représente par défaut l'épée valeur ces
styles p value si vous voulez un petit
peu plus d'informations vous pouvez
regarder ici donc par défaut
un exemple sur comment sont affichés par
défaut les pédaleurs
donc voyez c'est supérieur à 0,9 à
rouler une décimale jusqu'à 0,20 puis
arrondi à deux décimales est en dessous
quand on arrive à rentrer des simples
pour sont arrondis à trois décimales est
en dessous de 0 001 on a simplement un
symbole inférieur à 0 01 c'est une
manière commandé par certaines revues
justement de
arrondir en fait les pédaleurs en
fonction de la manière qui est
signifiant bien sûr si vous voulez
forcer un fichier open valeur avec les
trois chiffres on peut le faire si je
reviens la fonction ap
je regarde med vous avez évalué au fun
donc la fonction qui est utilisée pour
mettre en forme les valeurs et donc du
coup
ils value
fun je peux indiquer du coup
là on a utilisé
à
ger compte l'exemple ici
donc si je disais ce type et value
j'peux de soi indiqué frère chez nyx les
ouvrages indique à la volée du coup que
je veux une une
une
je crée à la volée une fonction qui
croient par m hic c'est qu'ils
appliquent ce type et value avec dj
segal 2
une halte à si
j'ai bien les deux chiffres qui seront
présentés les siens vous avez aussi une
alternative qui est de passer à dans les
fonctions de skype les fonctions la
belle danse qu'ils
s'agit bien de ça vient vous avez une
des fonctions qui est la belle et value
avec écurie si par exemple points 0,01
on va avoir trois chiffres et je vous
rappelle les fonctions de la belle dans
ce cas cela renvoie pas elle renvoie
d'une fonction de mise en forme or là
justement c'était attendu encore deux
fois c'est une fonction de mise enfants
ce qui est à retenir c'est que quand
vous appelez les fonctions de skins sa
part retenu le ça ne prend pas en compte
les paramètres du thème généraux donc là
c'est un point qui utilisait comme
séparateur donc c'est à nous de redire à
ce moment là
que
décimales marque il faut repasser du
coup les paramètres qui ici sont lui
arrive et
qu'on veut utiliser en fait un
séparateur décimales qui est la virgule
donc pareil pour tout ce qui est mise
enfants de dénombrer des cons faire des
choses un peu plus avancés comme je
voulais dit ne pas ça ne pas hésiter à
aller regarder du côté du chapitre
analyse est dédiée
qui est là
en plus sur ce chapitre vous verrez que
dans ce cas l on va avoir la mise en
forme de nombres pourcentage on a des
éléments pour mettre en forme des
données économiques
vous pouvez aussi mettre en forme des
données
scientifiques
ou même des ordinaux un nom français
pour pour écrire 1er 2ème 3ème 4ème dont
peu ça ça sert à la fois pour la mise en
forme des tableaux et ça sert également
pour la remise en forme dans les
graphiques donc un chapitre que je vous
conseille d'aller lire à l'occasion
alors
tant qu on y est je peux aussi vous
montrer
dans ce qu'on peut faire on peut aussi
avoir des intervalles depuis peu on peut
calculer intervalle de confiance
[Musique]
donc je vais vous présenter quelques
variables
et la fonction had c.é
alors at celi permet de rajouter des
intervalles de confiance
[Musique]
que ce soit des intérêts de confiance de
pourcentage comme vous avez ici 20le 29%
il va de 20 à 30 9% ou des intervalles
de confiance qui sont par défaut les
intervalles de confiance d'une moyenne
et comme par défaut présenta médiatis
aussi d'ailleurs là on le dit accès y
ajouter les intervalles de confiance
d'une moyenne pour marqueur mais il n'y
a pas de moyenne qui présentait donc
faut juste être un petit peu vigilants
dans quand on présente sam on a plutôt
intérêt à bien présente et préparer nos
statistiques ce donc là je vais dire que
pour toutes les variables continue je
vais représenter
la moyenne
et pour les bars et abl
catégorique on va représenter le pur
chantage
parce que du coup sinon on se retrouvait
des tableaux qui sont difficiles à lire
donc on va plus total a représenté que
la valeur qui nous intéresse
ici les moyennes avec les intervalles de
confiance où les proportions avec les
intervalles de confiance qui correspond
il est aussi possible de calculer alors
si on va regarder l'aide de la fonction
accès de t-bills mari vous avez un
paramètre méthode
d'accord qui vous permet aussi de
présenter par défaut on utilise la
fonction wyss wilson alors on utilise le
test de de wilson pour le calcul
des intervalles de confiance d'une
proportion donc ça va 2010 sonne c'est
avec un ajustement pour la prise en
compte de la de la correction continuité
plus à garder la fonction propres tests
si vous voulez voir plus clair sur ces
détails là et sinon vous avez de 3
autres méthodes qui sont proposés s'est
précisé en dessous pour les variables
pour les variables à
continue enfin c'est le test tequila
fonction des types tests utilisés pour
les intervalles de confiance donc c est
celui de la moyenne mais on peut aussi
calculer le matériel confiance des
médianes avec wilcock texte a donc c'est
pour ça que une des possibilités ce
serait éventuellement pour âge de
représenter
le tableau apprendre que marqueur h
réponse
je pourrais dire que je représentais la
moyenne l'âge médian
mais la moyenne pour marqueur
et dans ce cas là g
elle a représenté
ici je vais indiquer les méthodes
différentes
c'est à dire que la méthode elle sera
pour être correct pour l'âge il faut que
j'utilise du coup
l'intervalle de confiance du médiane
mais donc ça c'est avec la méthode
d'aplomb nicox
est on va calculer avec cette
fonction-là de mer on va calculer à
travers de confiance d'une louisiane
alors on bâtit la fonction anti peste
c'est vrai une fonction qui s'avère
comtesse de comparaison et pour calculer
intervalle de confiance pour celui de la
moyenne pour marquer
mais voyez
même city bylsma les permet de faire des
choses un peu plus simplifié avoue
malgré tout de garder une certaine qu
une certaine connaissance de ce que vous
faites pour faire représenter des choses
correctes et que je vais rajouter
à gstaad label
on y voit un peu plus clair de tableau
pour la statistique représentait
alors où est ce qu'il est pas le
contentement
qu'est ce qui manquait
n'a pas pris trop
il ya une erreur dans mon pote voilà un
expects et de symboles ici il manque les
véhicules en
voilà alors donc là on refait notre
tableau en entier
j'ai rajouté le staff label pour qu'on
puisse bien voir correctement le lac
estion statistiques on va peut-être
ajouter un petit mis ses mécanos pour
avoir quelque chose de plus lisible
j'ai effacé les valeurs manquantes
donc vous voyez là dans le tableau j'ai
la moyenne la médiane et un pourcentage
et points et donc j'ai utilisé des
méthodes différentes pour l'intervalle
de confiance de la moyenne on utilise du
coup le tester et pour le navire de
confiance de la médiane monteith du coup
le test ou rien
dernier point
alors je reviens rapidement les
questions qui sont là
il est demandé peut-on ramener les
totaux en bas du tableau alors je vois
pas de quel taux ou fait référence dans
le cas présent il n'y a pas de fonctions
ajoutées les taux tout en bas du tableau
parce que si jamais la question de
savoir quels sont les effectifs de
chacune des colonnes ils sont indiqués
ici dans l'en tête donc il ya l'idée de
total en ehpad en quête d'un tableau
croisé classique mais vous verrez tout à
l'heure la fonction thé ben cross façon
peut-être à la vision classique que vous
avez du tableau croisé
mais comme là en fait c'est plusieurs
varia présentés en fonction du nôtre où
il n'y a pas cette notion de total pour
les lignes
il est ici de l'ondé dans certaines
situations les données sont issues des
méthodes d'échantillonnage plus complexe
est ce que l'algorithme est il des rimes
usd prend en compte cela la fonction
thiblier se marient la fonction cibiel
somalie que je vous présente la en
détail elle est vraiment dans le cas de
figure classique des données c'est à
dire on est sur
des tests en l'absence de plan
d'échantillonnage ce qu'on avait vu et
je vous renverrai à la statistique
vivarié en contact d'échantillons
complexe c'est si vous avez un plan
d'échantillonnage complexe avec des ce
tract avec des grappes avec une
pondération
au fait vous pouvez définir le plan
d'échantillonnage complexe avec à vous
avec à kitchener
et dans ce cas là vous avez une fonction
d'enquêtés ce baby qui est à peu près
équivalente à tbl se marient mais qu'à
la fonction des bls vie à marie
et la fonction petit pierre yves
maillard ex mari elle va prendre comme
je donnais non pas un tableau classique
mais un objet sans arrêt avec son plan
d'échantillonnage avec sa pondération
est donc dans ce cas là tout les
cacahuètes corrigé par contre qu'il faut
retenir c'est que si vous vouliez faire
un add paix avec t-bills elle vit avec
son mari les tests qui sont proposés
pour la comparaison ne sont pas les
mêmes
vous verrez vous louez qu'il ya d'autres
thèses qui sont proposés parce qu'ils se
doivent être adaptés ils doivent être
adaptées à votre plan d'échantillonnage
complexe les tests qui sont proposées ce
sont des tests qui viennent du package
cervelle vous avez le test d adapter à
cacharel pour la prise en compte du plan
d'échantillonnage complexe vous avez
pour will coxon pour crucial pour von
durden donc les tests de comparaison
sont adaptés et quant aux statistiques
qui sont présentes et elles sont
également adaptés c'est à dire que la
statistique
les statistiques que vous avez sont
calculés avec un tipi à l'élever à
ismaily allaitent du package sauvé donc
vous avez un petit peu moins de choix
mais vous avez la médiane la moyenne les
cartes il votre écart type dans ce cas
là prend bien en compte
le plan d'échantillonnage complexes
ainsi qu'à sommes donc toutes les
statistiques qui sont calculées avec
tibet et six au mali sont calculés via
ce revers et prennent donc on compte les
corrections adéquat en fonction de la
pondération et du plan d'échantillonnage
notamment en matière de strates et de
craindre
par contre certaines fonctions sont pas
encore disponibles avec un package avec
l'aîné servait on vient de voir le hci
qui permet de rajouter des intervalles
de confiance de proportion et de médiane
et de moyenne ati n'est pas encore
compatible avec le paquet je servais
c'est une fonction qui est récente dont
keith et mary ainsi des fonctions qui
n'existaient pas aux dépens de débit des
webinaires ya un an vraiment le package
sps le baril évolue rapidement donc ces
fonctions là était pas encore
disponibles je pense qu'on aura une
fonction assez adapté au plan des
chantiers h complexe d'ici quelques mois
mais ce n'est pas encore le cas
une autre question qui était posée c'est
sur le test peut varier
est il possible de spécifier le test à
faire derrière faria nous par son rôle
de variables oui tout à fait on peut
faire
le test donc pour les tests pour hp ou
est-ce qu'il est l'exemple des actes et
il est ici donc quand on fait 1 ap on
peut
changer le test vous varia part variable
on va prendre un cas de figure
donc là on présentait marqueur âge
responsable donc tu poses on concrètes
comme ici ce qu'on va faire on va
leur prendre un ce tableau la de départ
donc là on a à gérer ce pont sur va pour
moi et donc on présente la médiane pour
agent présente la moyenne pour marqueur
d'accord donc on aimerait avoir un est
né sais pas mais ce qui nous intéresse
puisque on a intérêt à avoir
donc la faiblesse de la fonction à
modifier je m'affiche de la partie bilal
son mari
donc c'est est ce qu'on va faire ici ce
qu'on va faire est ce différent pour les
deux variables d'accord donc là j'ai
fait une liste tout simplement et j'ai
indiqué que pour âge le test qu'elle
veut utiliser donc l'âge c'est la
médaille car présenté devant la presse
de comparaison des médianes ctr tekki
montpoint comparaison donc je peux
utiliser un test
comme je n'ai que deux modalités je peux
comparer mes
médiane avec le test the wheel coxon
mais on va décider de faire le test
crucial willis pour changer qui est tout
aussi valable par contre pour la
variable marqueur qui est comparable en
moyenne là j'ai passé un inspecté de
student
parce que je compare des moyennes donc
là je me permets de m'assurer que
les ds qui sont cohérents avec ce que je
représente et puis on va faire c'est
parler de foot note
à
précision d'ailleurs envoyé pour
marqueur j'ai bien eu ici c'est le test
de donges un test de thé pour kruska
wallis appliqué à âge et un test du
guide est appliquée à la réponse tumeur
au pourcentage donc là j'ai bien pu
avoir des tests qui sont différents
parce quand on applique un séparer de
foot note il ya un petit problème
actuellement où c'est plus traduit vous
avez les noms anglais des tests si je
vous fais le tableau sur le séparait de
foudre vous verrez que vous aurez les
non français et l'est
pour votre information c'est un bug qui
a été rapporté ce matin qui a été
corrigé cet après-midi dans la version
de développement
d'objectifs selon lui donc encore une
fois il y aura des petites corrections
voilà c'est ses impacts et en tout cas
qui évolue assez rapidement et puis il
ya je vois le dernière question et ça
tombe bien ça va être ma transition pour
la dernière fonctionnalité qu'on va voir
aujourd'hui qu'une fonction d'arsenal où
c'est y at il une différence entre tibia
se marient et ibm cross alors on va voir
la différence tout de suite avec un
exemple
sur le principe c'est de fonctions qui
sont à peu près équivalente mais on peut
faire bien plus de choses avec tibia
leur lutte avec tibia cross le principe
de type cross c'est vraiment de faire un
tableau croisé classique trop longtemps
d'accord je prends moi donc
on va prendre sera rien
je deux arrières petits d'oriel une 1/2
arrière contre catégoriels pour qu'on va
appliquer tbl cross d'etel cross sont
d'abord lui indiquer le nom la variable
qu'on veut voir en ligne bros hbo pour
ligne 1 ou l'anglais donc une école pour
colonne donc on va appliquer la variable
guad sur les lignes et en colonnes on va
afficher la variable traitement
telle option percept pour dire le type
de pourcentage que je veux est ce que je
vous dis pourcentage en ligne blu en
colonne cole ou celle pour le docteur
donc si je fais ça
simples calculs montrent tableaux
croisés la différence c'est que voyez
j'ai tout de suite un bolide jénine
total au sens où c'était entendu donc
c'était un peu la question qui était
posée tout à l'heure pour les taux tout
en bas du tableau
il ya un total parce que sur un tableau
croisé cassiers qu'il ya ça fait sens de
faire une mine total ce qui est pas
forcément le cas pour
pour le losc est plus général etibel ce
ballet je montrerai dans moins de
petites solutions
tbl cross et une seule variable en ligne
seule variable en colonnes on peut pas
en mettre plusieurs il est possible de
faire
de faire un aspect
pour avoir du chi 2 qui est rajouté ici
dans une colonne mais on a aussi
l'option que ça paraisse uniquement
dans les
notes de bas de page si je fais source
note égale trop ça me rajoute juste moki
2 en bas donc tibet le cross est
vraiment dans la logique du tableau
croisé classiques tels convois entre
deux variables catégorielles ses pensées
pour deux variables catégorielles alors
que tbilissi mari et beaucoup large tibi
yen se marie on est vraiment dans la
logique de
on est dans la logique de présenter en
fait a résumé de plusieurs variables et
éventuellement de présenter ces s'est
résumé en fonction d'une variante
catégorielles alors je pourrais faire
quelque chose assez équivalent avec le
royaume cibiel
samarie
include égales entre
paul égal et
rtr cents 0
principale col sebaï
on va obtenir un tableau qui est à peu
près équivalent mais qu'un petit peu
différent et il ya automatiquement c'est
variable totale qu'on peut avoir avec du
coup un
ado bros
voilà ce qu'il faut retenir c'est qu'on
peut effectivement utile reproduire du
tableau croisé au sens stricte c'est
vraiment idéal cross qui me plaît
tellement croisé tel qu'on l'a vue de
manière
[Musique]
classique tibial somalie c'est plutôt
intéressant quand on va résumer beaucoup
beaucoup de données et dans ce cas il
n'y a pas cette notion totale parce que
certaines variations des données
manquantes différents donc c'est pour ça
qu'on a tous les effectifs totaux qui se
réfléchit encore
donc comme on l'a elle comme je voulais
dire puisque je vois que l'heure tourne
si vous deviez désolé qu'on dirait aller
du côté de tibet lsv america à peu près
les mêmes options à être un petit peu
moins d'options certaines choses sont
pas encore là a accès je vois qu'il ya
une dernière option que j'ai oublié de
vous présenter et qui peut être
important et c'est quelque chose d'assez
nouveau qui ait had différence
alors
l'iphone se passera on a vu les fesses
de comparaison a notamment il est
maintenant possible
de calculer alors la condition c'est que
votre variable
calculer une différence entre deux
pourcentages le moyenne alors attention
aujourd'hui a dit france accepte
uniquement que les variables bail à deux
niveaux ce qu'on va faire une différence
entre du groupe
et on peut calculer la différence entre
deux moyennes ou la différence entre
deux proportions mais que pour les paré
de dichotomie qu un bon c'est pas encore
le gérer pour des bars catégorielles et
ce qui va être fait c'est qu'on va
pouvoir afficher l'intervalle de
confiance de la différence la paix
valeurs associées pour voir si la
différence est significativement
différente 0 je vous montre un exemple
sachez que vous sachiez que ça existe un
à un
les fonctions qui sont encore un peu
récentes qui vont probablement évoluer
pour couvrir un plus grand nombre de cas
donc je vais prendre
les variables âge
marqueur et response
response elle est une variable
dichotomique un
bail trt donc par le traitement que moi
que deux modalités
au ca soit plus facile à suivre
les statistiques je présentais que les
moyennes et les pour son pelage donc
hall
continue hausse je vais présenter
uniquement
moyenne un comptage de quoi on parle et
bolatti gorille comme
uniquement
le pourcentage p
et puis
pour que ça soit aussi plus facile je
vais changer de nom l'ombre
1 2 chiffres par défaut donc dj égale
liste
pour les vannes continue on va mettre
deux chiffres que ça ne soit plus facile
la suit
et pour les pourcentages on va utiliser
qu'un seul chiffre
voilà le premier tableau qu'on va faire
donc j'ai un tableau d'accord je vais
cacher les manquant peut-être sont plus
faciles
doublant ce tableau on l'a la moyenne on
voit que la moyenne dans un groupe assez
47 01 pour l'ag 47 45 pour groupe b et
vous avez pour une variable
dichotomique 1 vous avez du coup un
pourcentage qui ont une réponse de la
tumeur sait on peut après il n'oubliait
pas que lorsque vous avez
a
plus une variable a trop quatre
modalités vous pouvez transformer en
différents arabe dichotomique ce qui se
passe c'est que si je rajoute à
différentes
donc il ya un peu une fonction aucune
nouvelle
et donc si votre variable bail n'a que
deux modalités un mot clé ça vous
calcule la différence entre les deux
groupes donc là j'ai une différence de
zéro car de -0 44 dans les moyennes
d'une différence de 0,26 entre les
moyennes et moins 4,2 ici entre les
pourcentages ça vous rajoute
l'intervalle de confiance à 95 % de
différence et la paix valeur de la
différence alors techniquement c'est un
test tant pour
pour les variables pour les moyennes et
puis c'est un propres tests pour les
pour les proportions retenez aussi que
là ça marche encore c'est un peu nouveau
donc voulait pas non plus pour les
données pondérées
on a un peu moins d'options disponibles
alors
je vois une toute dernière question il
existe en 56 est-ce que jetty cela me
permet aussi d'afficher et personnaliser
les résultats de l'analyse multivariée
notamment les régressions à tous la
chance de le voir le cas chez nous tout
à fait guy qui se marient permet avec
tibet l'immolation de présenter les
résultats des régressions
malheureusement on n'a pas encore eu le
temps de voir si aujourd'hui comme ça
fait déjà deux heures je vais m'arrêter
là pour ce soir et donc je vous propose
une nouvelle session dédiée du tice ma
vie où on abordera du coup comment est
ce qu'on fait avec les données de
régression mais il n'ya pas que ça parce
que ce qu'on a pas encore longtemps voir
c'est comment représenter aussi les
statistiques personnalisé avec steam et
elle continue ce site idéal custom
somalie qui permettent de représenter et
de faire des tableaux encore un peu plus
avancée et un tableau des incidences par
exemple où la moyenne de l'ars en
fonction de deux ou trois secondes
donc voilà on a donc encore de notre
escarcelle à revoir si bien continuer
c'est idéal costume se marient avoir
tiberi berrichonne qui permet de
représenter les résultats de régression
et puis
ce qu'on n'a pas encore vu
c'est comment est-ce qu'on peut combiner
le tableau avec td est acté mais le mer
jaune encore t'es belle strata qui
permet d'aller un peu plus loin on verra
aussi comment faire des régressions et
variés multiples avec tpm hubert védrine
on n'a pas abordé non plus la fonction
des belles-soeurs fit pour représenter
les résultats d'un club ailleurs
d'envoyer un mal de choses et puis
sachez qu'il ya un autre petit package
qui s'appelle le bes et funky un package
où on expérimente des choses avant que
ça intègre tutti somalie ou à vous allez
des options pour par exemple
représenter graphiquement les
coefficients dans un tableau avec d ilan
pelote ou encore t'es belle vigueur
après de multiples qui kate et encore
pas mal de choses à voir nous ferons
sensu une prochaine session
j'ai regardé toute dernière question à
quitter les questions pour eux pour
savoir si on peut avoir avec des tissus
mari un croisement des variables
indépendantes avec une variable
dépendante quantitatif c'est-à-dire avec
un bail quantitatif on n'a pas de quoi
faire un bye quantitatif ceci étant dit
si on avait besoin de résumer par
exemple une variable vous êtes intéressé
par l'ag vous voudrez représenter l'âge
moyen pour plusieurs sous groupes on
verra la prochaine fois mais tibet elle
continue ce qu'on pourrait représenter
l'âge moyen en fonction des différents
sont donc ça ça serait impossible c'est
pas avec thil elle se marie mais c'est
possible avec tibet a continué aussi
tibial custom son mari donc restez
connectés je pense que j'essaie de faire
cette prochaine session avant noël
peut-être la semaine prochaine si ces
joies donc cas je vous tiens au courant
déjà un créneau
du coup je vous souhaite à tous une très
bonne soirée je remercie aussi pour vous
remercie mais je suis ravi de redémarrer
ses séminaires sur de nouveaux sujets
vous douterez bien que j'ai promis de
refaire ce qui a déjà été fait la
semaine dernière puisqu'ils sont deux
façons
disponible à mai mais plus convient que
de
l'écouter de poursuivre l'aventuré de
faire de nouveaux sujets et je pense
qu'on décroche à bord d'un rapprochement
avec vous les différentes manières le
côté d'eva qualitative dans un modèle
dans une irrigation ce qu'on appelle les
contrastes voilà donc il y aura d'autres
choses qui vont arriver pour le coup je
vous souhaite une très bonne soirée je
vous dis à très bientôt et du coup être
très vite pour un prochain où les
binaires et on va continuer du coup sûr
qui se marie encore une bonne session
voilà très bonne soirée en voix